quatre hectares de terrain 5 km de
couloir le pop-corn labyrinthe de joueur
Pontchartrain réunis depuis le début de
l'été les familles au travers de
parcours au beau milieu des épis de maïs
c'est un grand labyrinthe il y a deux
parcours différents il y a soit le
parcours jeux en bois avec donc des
grands jeux en bois comme on peut voir
derrière moi donc il est destiné à tout
le monde adultes et enfants à partir de
4 ans et il y a le parcours à énigme
donc là c'est un jeu de piste à
l'intérieur du labyrinthe il y a 5
énigmes à résoudre donc ici c'est sur le
thème du Tour du monde en 80 jours pour
les plus téméraires des sessions
nocturnes à thème sont également
proposés il y a deux nocturnes
différentes il y a soit l'enquête
criminelle donc pour les ados adultes
c'est une sorte de Cluedo géant à
l'intérieur de nuit qui se fait la lampe
torche ou sinon une fois par mois donc
une fois en juillet une fois en août et
puis là dans le 24 septembre il y a une
nuit de l'horreur donc avec des zombies
qui sont cachés dans labyrinthe et qui
sont là pour faire peur aux gens qui
viennent se faire peur au travers des
différents parcours parents et enfants
peuvent se défier dans la bonne humeur
et au travers de jeux à la fois ludique
et pédagogique là pour l'instant on est
en train de faire le parcours des jeux
en bois donc on vient de faire le 1er
jeu en bois et ce qui est sympa c'est de
pouvoir s'amuser avec son enfant la
petite compétition mais gentiment et du
coup de laisser un petit peu gambader
pour trouver la sortie réfléchis ça lui
permet de se repérer dans l'espace aussi
tout ça donc voilà et avec des maïs de
plus de 2 mètres de haut il n'y a pas
que les enfants qui doivent mobiliser
leur capacité pour se repérer dans
l'espace est vraiment top souvent les
labyrinthes c'est toujours en bas et
pour les enfants et donc en tant
qu'adulte on est on voit souvent par
dessus et c'est un peu moins intéressant
et là du coup de le faire que ce soit
vraiment en plein champ et et
à taille réelle on va dire et c'est
vraiment super vous avez jusqu'au 25
septembre pour profiter du labyrinthe de
quoi passer un bon moment en famille
sans oublier de trouver la sortie